[Applaudissements]
bien moi j'aime particulièrement deux
jeunes chanteurs tout à fait dans le
vent il s'agit d'Enrico Matias et
d'Alain
Barrière c'est pas une
[Applaudissements]
intru alors chant à deux voix tu chantes
avec moi ah non non je te laisse chanter
vas-y mon
frère je ne sais pas trop
pourquoi ce soir je
chante je ne sais pas trop pour
pourquoi ce soir mon
chanteur je ne sais pas trop pourquoi
j'ai ce
sourire et plutôt que d'en pleurer je
veis en
[Musique]
rire il y a comme un
parfum qui me
[Musique]
transporte et m'emmène loin très loin
des amours
mort et c'est peut-être
pourquoi dans mon délire
oui plutôt que d'en pleurer je veux en
rire certes elle est partie bien loin de
notre
ville et je sais mes l de
bien
[Musique]
difficile certes l'on ne connaît bien
que ce qu'on
quitte et je sais que les regrets nous
viennent
vite je ne sais pas trop
pourquoi ce soir je
[Musique]
chante je ne sais pas trop pourquoi
ce soir mon
chanteur je ne sais pas trop
pourquoi j'ai ce
[Musique]
sourire et plutôt que d'en
pleurer je veux en
rire en
[Musique]
rire